The holiday season means
food, presents, family,
and also travel.
Lots and lots of travel.
And with these gas
prices, wouldn't you
want your vehicle to
be more efficient?
Hey, drivers.
Trace here for D News with
some holiday knowledge
that I'm going to drop on you.
Automobiles opened up
the world for individuals
to travel as far as they
wanted on their own schedule.
But gasoline, man?
Fossil fuel.
It's a huge drawback
on so many levels,
climate and environmental
effects, and the cost.
So to fight back,
our government now
requires manufacturers to
create more efficient cars.
And with those efficiencies
growing a lot from now to 2025,
we thought, how are
they going to do that?
Since the invention of better
transmissions, fuel injection
systems, emission controls
and other technologies,
our cars have pulled more
power with less fuel.
But we've kind of hit the wall.
It seems it's hard to make
an engine more efficient,
and that's not the
best way to go.
Instead, automakers are opting
to shed pounds and reduce drag.
Aerodynamics can be beneficial.
For example, a boxy truck would
have a lot more difficulty
pushing through the air
than a sleek sports car.
The better the
aerodynamics of a car,
the less drag you get from air
resistance, thus a lower drag
coefficient.
If you can reduce the
drag coefficient by 0.01,
you'll gain 0.2
miles per gallon.
If you're not using your
roof rack, take it off.
You'll reduce your drag.
If you've got an
antenna topper up there,
you're increasing your drag.
Seriously, get rid of
that stupid things.
Making the car
lighter is another way
the manufacturer can make
a car more fuel efficient.
If they cut weight,
they'll have less car
to pull with the same engine.
This is why sports
cars are usually
made of ultra light materials,
like aluminum and carbon fiber.
Even shaving just a few ounces
off of the physical gas pedal
could save a tiny
amount of fuel.
The US Department of Energy
says if automakers reduce weight
by 10%, the car will get a bump
of 6% to 8% in fuel efficiency.
However, since most
of us don't want
to put a file to our
cars' metal parts,
there are strategies
all of us can
use to improve our gas mileage.
The US Department of Energy
says the quickest way is also
to cut weight.
Carrying 100 lbs of extra
cargo and baggage in the car
will reduce your fuel
efficiency by 2%.
So leave those party
supplies at home,
because you don't need them.
The second easiest
way is to make sure
that your tires are at
the proper pressure.
Yeah, I know this seems
kind of silly and whatever,
but it's actually way
better, because most of us
drive on under
inflated tires, which
increases the friction
with the road,
decreasing fuel
efficiency by like, 7%.
Driving slower will also
reduce the coefficient of drag,
and increase gas mileage.
The most efficient speed
is 55 miles an hour.
That's where aerodynamics,
power, and fuel,
and efficiency,
they all line up.
Each five mile increase over
50 will decrease your economy
by another 7% every five miles.
I know it seems like the
world is kind of nickel
and diming you here, but hey,
that's how physics works, guys.
Over time, like, say, a year,
if you can improve your gas
mileage by 7%, you would
save hundreds of dollars.
Do you have other strategies
to improve your gas efficiency?
Tell us down below,
and thanks a lot
for watching D News, everybody.
Click that Subscribe button,
and have a great holiday season.
Drive safely.